Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. We're back. Nice to see
you, Martin. Sorry. Yes, it's nice to
see you again. Yes, I haven't seen you
in a long, long time. At least 10
minutes ago.
Yeah, you shouldn't say that. Then
people are going to think we This is all
we do. Yes, you're right. Yeah. Okay,
never mind. Just carry on. Well, before
we begin, let's ask the Lord to bless
the discussion again. Let's pray. Our
heavenly father, thank you for bringing
us together again in a world that
is quickly rushing towards the end.
Please enlighten our minds and lead the
discussion to glorify your name in Jesus
name. Amen. Amen.
Martin, we've titled this one
desolate. Now, last time we spoke about
the seal of God. Yeah. Or the mark of
the beast
or what's the mark of Cain? Right. Yes.
And we looked at all of those
issues and certain theologies and
certain actions by
uh the people in the world and by God's
church can lead to the point where God
declares them desolate.
That's a very sad state. Very sad state.
It happened quite a few times. Your
house has been left to you desolate.
That's totally emptied. Emptied of what?
Of the spirit of God. Yeah. So something
terrible must be happening. So what does
it mean? Desolate. So we we're going to
look at that because we need to
understand the issue in terms of what is
happening in the world. So we said we're
going to look at it a little bit more
from a theological point of view and
then we can go back to what's happening
next in history. Yeah. Then you can put
it into the prophetic picture again.
Yes. Because if we if we neglect to put
it into a scriptural framework, we miss
the point. That's then it's just news.
Yes. And that's the last thing we want
to be is a news agency. We don't want to
be a news agency. Although news is
interesting as it pertains to
prophecy. Matthew
24:15, "When ye therefore shall see the
abomination of
desolation, spoken of by Daniel the
prophet, stand in the holy place, who so
readeth, let him understand." M now if
you went to the parallel verse which we
didn't put up here in the Gospel of Luke
then it'll read the same about the
abomination of desolation etc etc and it
says when you see the armies surrounding
Jerusalem
so that's the armies of Rome
literal Jerusalem was destroyed by
literal pagan in
Rome. Now, in an end time
uh scenario, this abomination of
desolation spoken of by the prophet
Daniel will not be the armies of pagan
Rome, but they must be armies of those
who wield the sign of Anu. Yes. It's
also Rome, but in a papal form. Yeah. In
a garb of godliness. Yes. And this sign
of Anu was transferred
uh to act on behalf of this first piece.
And we spoke about that in our last
discussion.
So when I see this
army, this power structure that will
force the world and I see it developing
and I see it getting its Roman footprint
by leaders putting on, you know, signs
of the ash and of subservience to this
Roman system. In other words, when the
church and the state come together and
the state is portraying the aspects of
one particular religion in particular,
then I must start worrying about the
abomination of desolation.
So what is this abomination that makes
desolate?
Obviously, it must refer to the mark of
the beast. That's true. Because after
the mark of the beast comes desolation.
Yeah. Destruction. Destruction. So it
can't be anything else. So once the mark
of the beast has been applied, then
comes desolation and
destruction. But in order for the mark
of the beast to be applied, there must
first come a desolation of the mind.
Yes. A moving away from what God Yes.
Because why would you accept it if you
didn't have the right mindset or the
that mindset, the wrong mindset, right?
Mhm. So Martin this whole picture
becomes very interesting. So when in the
ancient times in 70 AD they saw the
armies standing in the holy
place. Then you had to go and study the
book of Daniel. Yeah. So the army the
first army's surrounding was before 70
AD. Yes. That was when they knew okay
now they must study the prophets. And
then there was a second
surrounding and because they had studied
the book of Daniel they knew what was
going on. So there would be these
attempts to take over. So Martin when
you see this happening then study your
Bible and study the book of Daniel.
God here deliberately specifically
points to the book of Daniel study. It's
actually important to realize you should
study it now. Yes. Like they had to
study it before the second one because
then there was there was too late.
Correct. Now it's interesting that Mark
also uses this terminology. But when you
shall see the abomination of desolation
spoken of by Daniel the prophet standing
where it ought not. Yeah, that's very
interesting. So there it was the holy
place. Now it is where it ought not. It
shouldn't be there. It shouldn't be
there. Church and state should be
separate. You shouldn't have Rome and
out of both of them, the secular and the
spiritual have one. Yeah. Yeah. Like
Georgetown University says it should.
That sword that's wielded. Correct. Let
him that readeth understand. L Let them
that be in Judea flee to the mountains.
So this is all very interesting
uh stuff that we have to compare what
happened then and what's happening now.
Isn't it almost also like come out of
her my people? Oh absolutely. Run for
your life. The prayer of Christ is not
for those only who were then his
disciples but for all who shall believe
on him through the words of his
disciples even to the end of the world.
Jesus was just about to yield up his
life to bring life and immortality to
light. Amid his sufferings and daily
rejection, Christ looks down the
line 2,000 years to his church in the
last days. This is almost like a
prophecy that it'll only take 2,000
years from the time of Christ to the end
of the world. Right. Well, it's not
written um approximately 2,400 years.
No. So, the Lord has had a church from
that day through all the changing scenes
of time to the present day. The prayer
of Christ sets before us a model church.
They are to be in unity with each other
and with God. When believers are united
to Christ, the living vine, they are one
with Christ, filled with sympathy and
tenderness and love, let every soul echo
that prayer in mind, in petition, in
exaltation, that they may be one, as
Christ is one with the Father, and work
to this end. Instead of turning the
weapons of warfare upon those within our
own ranks, let them be turned against
the enemies of God and the truth.
So Martin the message that has to go to
the world is not a message that you
pound the church with that keep the
commandments and hold to the testimony
but one that warns the world so that
they can come out of her my people. It's
like you mentioned in a previous
one the the watchmen on the walls of
Zion is not supposed to look inward. No,
they should look out. They should have
very strong binoculars and should be
watching outside what is happening out
there to warn the people that they
should not go along with these issues.
So we are not to hover over the churches
to keep them propped up. We are supposed
to preach the three angels messages.
Jesus declared to the listening
disciples the judgments that were to
fall upon apostate Israel. Now remember
that is a type of what will happen at
the end, right? Because Matthew 24 is a
then time end time
prophecy and especially the retributive
vengeance that would come upon them for
their rejection and crucifixion of the
Messiah. This is the issue.
unmistakable signs would precede the
awful climax. The dreaded hour would
come suddenly and swiftly. The Savior
warned his followers, "When he therefore
shall see the abomination of desolation
spoken of by the prophet Daniel, stand
in the holy place. Whoso readeth, let
him understand, then let him which is in
Judea flee into the mountains." Quoting
Matthew and Luke. when the idolatrous
standard of the Romans should be set up
in the holy
ground where Mark said where it should
not be. Yeah. Yeah. Which extended some
furlongs outside the city wall. Then the
followers of Christ were to find safety
in flight. When the warning sign should
be seen, those who would escape must
make no delay. throughout the land of
Judea as well as in Jerusalem itself.
The signal for flight must be
immediately obeyed. He who chants to be
upon the housetop must not go down into
his house, even to save his most valued
treasures. Those who were working in the
fields or vineyards must not take time
to return for their outer garments laid
aside while they should be toiling in
the heat of the day. They must not
hesitate a moment lest they be involved
in general
destruction. I believe we are living
between two sieges.
I believe so too. There was already an
attempt to bring in legislation and
Sunday legislation in the Blair and we
are waiting now for the second siege.
This is the time when you must be
warning people. You must have your
binoculars on and you must see if that
Roman army is approaching even into the
ranks and heart of the church where it
shouldn't be. Yeah. Right. For sure. It
shouldn't be there. The blood of Christ
and of the disciples whom they had put
to death was upon them, upon the Jews,
speaking about them as a nation, Martin,
not as individuals. Because thousands of
Jews embraced the Messiah.
and terrible judgments were they
visited. The curse of God followed them
and they were a byword and derision to
the heathen and to
Christians. And then let's drop down
here. Some will yet see that prophecy
has been filled concerning them and they
will receive Jesus as the savior of the
world and see the great sin of their
nation in rejecting Jesus and crucifying
him. individuals amongst the Jews will
be converted. And it's happening all the
time. Yeah. But as a
nation, they are forever forsaken of
God. When Jesus said, "Your house is
left to you desolate,"
he didn't say for a while. No, he did
not say that. And it was not to be
maintained as the people representing
God because they had rejected the
Messiah.
The Christian
church which in its first years was
comprised solely of Jews or virtually
only of Jews.
They were the ones they just who were to
carry forward the message of salvation.
That same message that started in Eden,
correct? It never changed. But as a
nation, they were forever forsaken of
God. If you if you deny the Messiah,
you've missed the point. Yeah. Right.
Completely. You've missed the point. So
Martin, the house and the temple were
destroyed and desolate.
Then the pope here who is praying at the
wailing wall is actually symbolizing
that he wants a resurrection of the
temple.
But Paul quite clearly says that the
church has become the temple of the
living God. Yes. And not one stone will
be left. And that one man will deem
himself a god on earth and will try and
sit in that church pretending that he's
God and making rules and breaking the
seal of God and putting his own seal in
the place thereof. There's a
representative. Here is a quote from the
Israel of God. Palmer Robertson on the
Israel of God. He states that the
recognition of a distinctive people who
are the recipients of God's redemptive
blessings and yet who have a separate
existence apart from the church of Jesus
Christ creates
insuperable theological problems.
Jesus Christ has only one body and only
one bride, not two.
One people that he claims as his own,
which is the true Israel of God. This
one people is made up of Jews and
Gentiles who believe that Jesus is the
promised Messiah. So I'm not the only
one saying that, Martin.
This has been the watchword of the
reformers from their inception. Right.
There you go.
So Martin Luther when speaking on
Galatians
6:16 he says upon the Israel of God here
Paul attacks the false apostles and the
Jews who boasted about their fathers
their election the law etc. It is as
though he was saying the Israel of God
are not the physical descendants of
Abraham, Isaac, and Israel. But those
who with Abraham, the believer, believe
in the promises of God now disclosed in
Christ, whether they are Jews or
Gentiles. Yeah. Isn't he saying the
exact same thing? Exactly the same
thing. So Martin, can we have true two
organizations living side by side, both
claiming to be God's representatives and
people on this earth, the one accepting
the Messiah and the other rejecting him?
Doesn't make any sense. No, not if they
claim to be both from God. No. So when
we read that as a nation they are
forever forsaken of God then we must
read because they rejected the Messiah.
Yeah. They haven't accepted him
finished. And if they say that they are
waiting for the Messiah now they make it
quite clear that it's not Jesus they're
waiting for. Yeah.
In fact their Talmud says some very
terrible things about Jesus and what he
is going through. Right. Let's not go
there. So when they want to build the
third temple, Martin, isn't that a
blasphemy? Completely. That's throwing
Jesus out completely. That's totally
negating Jesus. Now they became desolate
because they rejected the Messiah and
his teachings. When the Christian church
follow suit, will they not also become
desolate? Oh, for sure.
So Martin, we are told that the beast of
revelation which we have at Nosia said
that it was the Roman Catholic system.
Yeah.
The same applies here that it's not the
Jews you're talking about. It's them as
a system as a nation and Catholicism as
a system and as a nation because they
are qualified as a nation that they have
certain issues which make their house
desolate. Yeah. The teachings and
doctrines and all of those. So let's see
what their problem was. Well, when you
go to Revelation
53 verse 5 and 6. And there was given
unto him a mouth speaking great things
and blasphemies.
So obviously it was a blasphemous power
against God.
And power was given unto him to continue
40 and two months. Well, we just read in
the last one that we
did that he said that he's above the
Bible, right? That's a blasphemous
statement. And then verse six tells us
what his blasphemy is all about.
and he opened his mouth in blasphemy
against
God to blasphe the following his name
that's his character
and his character is embodied in the law
and that must be sealed in your forehead
right
so he blasphemes against the law of god
which stands for the character of god a
little bible study will shows that the
character and and attributes of Christ
are
identical to those of the law for sure.
And his tabernacle,
his church. How do you blaspheme a
tabernacle?
Basically, the tabernacle was the temple
because it was first a tent and then it
was built into a temple. So what did the
tabernacle stand for? It stood for the
typeology of salvation.
Okay. Yeah. the atonement. Correct. So
if you have this picture over here of
the tabernacle, then you entered into
the door
and Christ said he's the door. Yeah. You
were confronted by the altar of burnt
offering and there was a lamb that was
to be sacrificed and you had to confess
your sins, place your hands on the lamb
and then it was sacrificed and that
stood for Jesus
Christ who paid the price for you and
became the sacrificial lamb. When you
entered into the door, you were covered
by surrounded by this white linen wall
which represents the righteousness which
is of Christ. That's
justification. So you accepted
justification by faith. Yeah. You were
washed at this labor by the washings of
rebirth. Then you entered into the holy
place where you received instruction on
the light of the world, the candlestick,
which is the word of God, fed by the
oil, which is the Holy Spirit.
You were embibing in the bread of his
presence. I am the living bread that
came down from heaven. That's the word
of God. You're internalizing it. And you
looked at the altar of incense where
Christ was mediating on your behalf.
And on the other side in the most holy
was the ark with the ten commandments
and the mercy seat. So that was the plan
of salvation. You accept Christ as your
savior. You're covered by the
righteousness of Christ. The sacrificial
lamb died for you. You confess your
sins. He pays the price for you. He
washes you. He sanctifies you through
embibing in his word, becoming in
harmony or coming into harmony with his
principle, internalizing them, accepting
his mediation, thanking him for being
the mercy seat, shielding you from the
condemnation of the law, and you come
back into harmony with his requirements.
Go and sin no more. That was the plan of
it's like writing it in your forehead
and in your hand. Correct. implementing
it. So when he blasphemes against the
tabernacle, then somehow he must change
what happens here in this tabernacle.
For example, he says, well, you can't go
directly to Christ because the Catholic
doctrine says when you go directly to
Christ, you can only come there with
fear and trembling. So you have to
invoke the mediation of Mary and the
saints. Uhhuh. To do it on your behalf.
Is that changing the tabernacle
completely? He says there is no
atonement. Jesus never died for you. He
died an act of obedience. But he didn't
die for you and you still have to pay
the price of yourself in purgatory.
You're going to burn off that price that
you owe. But doesn't that negate the
tabernacle over here? For sure. And then
he says you have to obey the authentic
teachings of the church
and their laws or you will be a heretic
and be disobeying. So that means you
don't need the word you need the
teachings of the church. That's
tradition. Yeah. And the bread of the
presence he gives you a host a repeated
sacrifice of what is happening over
here. In other words by one sacrifice he
has forever made perfect but by a
perpetual sacrifice. And the law he
changed. Yeah. And he isn't the mercy
seat after all because you have to come
to him with fear and trembling. But
doesn't he blasphe the tabernacle
completely? And you also have to go
through a human, not through Jesus to do
all of this. And then he blasphemes them
that dwell in heaven. Well, Martin,
that's God. And that is the angels.
Yeah. Well, he depicts the angels as
little fat babies flying around.
That is pretty awful. And he says that
Jesus was a generated being. Yes, the
father generated him. The father
generated them and the two together suk
blew the holy ex spirit into existence.
But uh in him was life unborrowed,
underived. Yes, he had life within
himself. God. Isn't that blaspheming
God? For sure.
So Martin, if you deny the way in which
you were saved through the blood of the
lamb, then you are denying the principle
of justification.
Yes. Now Martin, isn't that rejecting
the Messiah completely? Because then
you're doing it. That's what Cain did.
All right. So let's look at the theology
of Martin Luther. This one and firm rock
which we call the doctrine of
justification insisted Luther is the
chief article of the whole Christian
doctrine which comprehends the
understanding of all godliness. You
throw that one out, you have rejected
the Messiah. You might call your God by
that name. But if you deny
justification and you put the works of
Cain in the place of the works of Abel,
then you receive them another mark.
Yeah. So for
Luther, tradition, the doctrine of
salvation by grace alone through faith
alone for Christ's sake alone is the
material principle on which all other
teachings rest. You deny that, you deny
the tabernacle.
So here's another quote from the book
faith and works which says let the
subject be made distinct and plain that
it is not possible to affect anything in
our standing before God or in the gift
of God to us through creature merit.
There's nothing I can do to be saved.
Should faith and works purchase the gift
of salvation for anyone, then the
creator is under obligation to the
creature. Here is an opportunity for
falsehood to be accepted as truth. If
any man can merit salvation by anything
he may do, then he is in the same
position as the Catholic to do penance
for his sins. Then he's paying for it.
Salvation then is partly of debt at that
may be earned as wages. Yeah. So Martin,
this is the principal
issue. We saw that ancient Israel
rejected the Messiah and their house
became desolate. Any organization that
continues to reject it to reject him as
the Messiah is desolate. That's it.
There's nothing there. Now, what about
the church that embraces him? Can I go
the same route? If they shift their
principles in any form or fashion
regarding this then they're doing the
same just on a more subtle level. Yeah.
Then they become desolate. Isn't that
so? For sure. If you align with this in
any way you're going to get desolate.
Desolate. Do you want to be desolate?
Devoid of the spirit of God? Definitely
not. So let's just make sure. who was
cursed at the council of
T. Well, here we have it. This is their
writing. Anyone who says that sinners
are justified by faith
alone so as to mean that nothing else is
required to cooperate in order and to
obtain the grace of justification, let
him be an
anathema. So if there if you say that it
is through Christ's
atonement alone that you are
saved then you are an
anathema because they say no you have to
do it the way of Cain. You have to bring
your own works. You have to do your own
works. Can you see why we had to talk
about the mark of Cain in the last
episode? You have to make it very clear
and this is a very dangerous thing to do
because in this you all you also have uh
something that you can do to attain this
justification. And anyone who says that
sinners are justified by the sole
imputation of the righteousness of
Christ or by the sole remission of sins
without the charity which is shed abroad
in the hearts by the Holy Ghost without
infused grace let him be an anathema.
Martin this is so contrary to the
scriptures. So this this so it's the
opposite of Protestantism. Yeah. because
this takes away the completeness that
Christ is doing for you for you. But
what about the present uh joint
proclamation on the justification where
they say by grace alone through Christ's
saving works which is totally wrong
already. It started
1999 and everybody has signed on to that
thing by faith alone through his atoning
blood. That's it. So it is a twisted way
of getting people to accept Cain's
offering.
So the Vatican official foundational
starting point is man himself. In other
words, not Christ. This comes from the
Vatican 2 document. God is me. It is man
himself who must be saved. It is mankind
that must be renewed. It is man
therefore is the key to this discussion.
You know, Martin, I want to get ill.
Yeah. Because my salvation, if it relies
on man, I might as well forget it. No,
because this is exactly Cain theology.
This is Kane's theology. Man considered
whole and entire. Where's Jesus in this?
No. No. No way. With body and soul,
heart and conscience, mind and will.
This is the reason why the sacred senate
in proclaiming the noble destiny of man
and affirming an element of the divine
in him that's
blasphemy offers to cooperate
unreservedly with mankind in fostering a
sense of brotherhood to correspond to
their
destiny.
Martin this is a negation of the entire
gospel of justification. Yeah. It's it's
a terrible premise. It's completely
getting rid of Christ. So in the Roman
system, the house is desolate for long.
For Yes. So now she's fallen because it
says on her forehead,
the mother of Harland, Babylon. Yeah.
Fallen. So she's fallen. But what about
Protestantism?
So what is the Roman Catholic
understanding of justification? This
comes from Catholic do. It's their
encyclopedia.
Justification, it's carefully written.
Transformation of sinner from
unrighteous to holiness and sunship.
Martin that's not justification. No.
Because you are never made holy. You
have only an imputed holiness. You have
an
alien righteousness that has been
granted to you by Christ. Never in
scripture are you made holy. And you it
comes back to the mercy seat. Correct.
It's the only way you can be holy if you
want to put it like that is when the
mercies is on top. If it's and then it's
Christ that's his Christ's righteousness
it is an imputed righteousness. But they
said if you say it's an imputed
righteousness then you are an anathema.
Yeah. All right. Then they say which
denotes the transforming of the sinner
from a state of unrighteousness to a
state of holiness and sunship of God.
This is totally totally the opposite of
what scripture says. Let's go to
scripture to make
sure. So let's go by way of contrast.
Romans 3 28. Therefore we conclude that
a man is justified by faith without the
deeds of the law. Is this Paul here an
anathema according to them? Yes, he must
be. Right. They Yeah.
Therefore, being justified by faith that
we have peace with God through our Lord
Jesus Christ. Is he an anathema? Yep.
Knowing that a man is not justified by
the works of the law, but by the faith
of Jesus Christ, even we have believed
in Jesus Christ, that we might be
justified by the faith of Christ. and
not by works of the law. For by the
works of the law shall no flesh be
justified. Is he an anathema
completely? Martin is have we gone
insane or has the world gone insane? The
world I mean it's they've swallowed all
this Cain theology because the problem
also here is it's again of Jesus the
faith of Jesus Christ. Correct. Romans
4:11, "And he received the sign of
circumcision," talking about Abraham, a
seal of the righteousness of the faith,
which he had yet being uncircumcised.
So without works, right? That he might
be the father of all them that believe,
though they be not circumcised, the
righteousness might be what to him?
Imputed. What did they say? If you say
that your righteousness is imputed,
anathema and therefore it was imputed to
him for
righteousness. Martin is the house
desolate for sure. Oh, but it's now it
was not written for his sake alone that
it was imputed to
him, but for us also to whom it shall be
imputed. Paul is a heretic. Yeah.
If we believe on him that raised up
Jesus our Lord from the dead. No wonder
the book of Romans was such a jewel in
the hands of Martin Luther. But also no
wonder it's written to Rome.
That's very good point. Thank you for
that.
So no wonder after looking at this
dichotomy and this disconcordance of
thinking Martin Luther came to this
conclusion that the woman who was riding
the beast was none other than the pope
and the kings were paying paying
obeyance to the system rather than to
Jesus Christ. Yeah. So what did he call
it then? He said nothing else than the
kingdom of Babylon and the very
antichrist. For who is the man of sin
and the son of pedition but he who by
his teaching and his ordinances
increases the sin and pition of the soul
in the church while he sits in the
church as if he were God. All these
conditions have now been many ages be
fulfilled by the papal tyranny. That's
what Martin Luther concluded. Yeah. And
since they haven't changed that
doctrine, I have no choice but to agree
with him. That you cannot they can't
cannot be any other. Here is the history
of the reformation by
Abin. And it says Luther proved by the
revelations of Daniel and John. This is
the revelation by the epistles of Paul
and Peter and Jude that the reign of
Antichrist predicted and described in
the Bible was the papacy. He didn't
suggest it. He proved
it and all the people did say amen. A
holy terror seized their souls. It was
antichrist whom they beheld seated in
the pontipical throne. This new idea
which derived greater strength from the
prophetic descriptions launched forth by
Luther in the midst of his
contemporaries inflicted the most
terrible blow on Rome.
If those days hadn't been shortened,
nobody would survive. So God in his
mercy inflicted this terrible blow on
Rome. But it took
another few uh centuries to take away
his temporal power. Or so it seemed.
They were still he just went underground
and is now popping up in the United
States of America. Yep. Okay. So
everybody was agreed but now nobody is
agreed. No.
Why? Because Jesuits who hate the Bible
and hate the
Reformation came up with this
dastardly Jesuit theology of futurism.
That the Pope cannot be the Antichrist
because he's only coming in the future.
So please take your entire Bible, throw
it away. It doesn't apply to you. You
will be raptured. You will have none of
these problems to deal with. And only
the Jews are going to struggle with it
in the future because they are the
chosen of people of earth and therefore
they need a homeland. So let's create
one through the Rothschilds. Yeah.
Nothing to do with the Bible. It's
forever desolate. That's it. Now here's
another system that is desolate that has
managed to
sidestep the
reformation. So the Review Herald has
this to say. While the Protestant world
is by her attitude making concessions to
Rome like redefining the doctrine of
justification. Yes, we should arouse to
comprehend the situation and view the
contest before us in its true bearings.
Let the watchmen, didn't we, we speak
about them? Yep. Now lift up their
voices like a trumpet and give the
message which is present truth for this
time.
Let them know where we are in prophetic
history that the spirit of true
Protestantism may awaken all the world.
What is true Protestantism? Number one,
it is
protestari for the scriptures and
protesting against the falsehood of Rob.
That's it. That's what we have to do.
That's our marching order. I see a lot
of people still do that.
Yes, Martin.
Christ looked down the ages. He saw how
real Christianity would become almost
extinct so that at the second advent he
would find a state of society similar to
that which existed before the flood.
Even the churches would be demoralized
and the Bible would be neglected and
desecrated. That's what I'm You don't
even believe the first sentence in the
Bible in the beginning God. What about
the rest? Right.
So Martin, is it necessary that we
practice all diligence?
Yes. Keep thy heart. Proverbs 4:23. With
all diligence, for out it are the issues
of
life. Second Peter. And besides this,
give all diligence. Add to your faith
virtue. To virtue knowledge. To
knowledge temperance. To temperance
patience. To patience godliness. to
godliness, brotherly kindness, to
brotherly kindness, charity. So, agape
love is the final thing. You must love
your neighbor enough to warn
him. That is not to satisfy him and not
to condemn him. Yes. So, what does all
diligence mean? It means much. It means
a daily diligence. There's danger that
we shall be blind in regard to the
working of satanic agencies. I think the
world's become blind, Martin. They don't
see it anymore. Oh, for sure. Didn't you
also mention about Sam Samson? Mhm. How
blind he was. And even only when he was
completely blind did he finally see. He
did he finally see. Correct. Maybe the
world will hopefully see through all
this. Hopefully, hopefully they will
rise from their blindness and that you
shall be ins snared by satanic alluring
temptations. Therefore, the word comes
to us giving all diligence. Add to your
character the graces that will make you
strong to resist evil. He that lackth
these things is blind and cannot see a
far off. He does not realize his
spiritual poverty.
Wherefore the rather, brethren, give
diligence to make your calling and
election sure. For if you do these
things, you shall never fall. For so an
entrance shall be ministered unto you
abundantly into the everlasting kingdom
of our Lord Jesus Christ. Martin, we
need to study. We need to understand
where we are standing in the stream of
time and with diligence. Yes, that is so
important. So Martin Luther stated that
the whole world takes offense at the
plainness of the second table of God's
ten
commandments because human sense and
reason partly understand what is done
contrary
thereto and his word is condemned the
world is
silent and regards it not but when a
monastery is taken or flesh eaten on a
fried Friday Martin, I see they're
giving fishburgers now in the United
States and advertising it for Lent. Or a
frier marries. Oh, then the world cries
out, "Here are abominable offenses."
Isn't that brilliant? That's excellent.
You can even apply it
to nobody says a word when Christianity
is blown in a movie or something. But
let them just take another religion and
say something against it. Oh, then
everything is wrong. And now it seems
that if you speak against Catholic
doctrine, then you are an
abomination. But what if that doctrine
has nothing to do with the Bible?
They don't care that they are trampling
on the law of God. But don't trample on
eating fish on a
Friday. So obedience towards
God is the obedience of faith and good
works. That is he who believes in God
and does what he has commanded is
obedient unto him. But obedience towards
the devil is superstition and evil
works. that is who trusts not in God but
is unbelieving and does evil is obedient
unto the devil. And Paul said, "I don't
want you to worship with demons or to
worship
demons." Martin, the world is upside
down. It doesn't know what is evil
anymore because it has rejected the word
and the law. So Martin, if you reject
Christ, then you become desolate. Yes.
If you blaspheme the tabernacle and the
plan of salvation and replace it with
another plan of salvation, you become
desolate. So now the
Protestants who embraced the plan of
salvation and recognized that
righteousness is imputed to you and that
it is the righteousness of Christ and
not your own that gives you the title to
heaven. What if they start changing
their situation? Don't they also then
become desolate? For sure. If you align
yourself with the other one, even if you
go into an ecumenical council that you
are bound to become desolate, you're in
big trouble. All right. So now Daniel
9:17. Now therefore, oh our God, hear
the prayer of thy servant and his
supplications, and cause thy face to
shine upon thy sanctuary that is
desolate for the Lord's sake. So in the
time of
Daniel, the temple had been destroyed.
It was desolate. Why? Because because
they no longer practiced what they
should be practicing. Yeah. It was dis
disobedience. It became a gospel of
works and
apostasy. Daniel 9:27, "And he shall
confirm a covenant with many for one
week." Now, futurism applies this to the
antichrist sometime in the
future. But this has to do with the
Messiah, with Jesus Christ. And in the
middle of the week, he the Messiah will
put an end to the sacrificial system. So
by his death, he became the ultimate
sacrifice.
and for overspreading of abominations he
shall make it desolate. Here is a
kayazm. You had the ruler opposed to the
ruler. So you have the Roman opposed to
the messiah. So the messiah would would
make an end to the sacrificial system
and
then through his death. Yeah. And then
would come the Roman legions and destroy
the temple. And this would be until the
end.
This is
very interesting. Daniel 11:31, "And
arms shall stand on his part, and they
shall pollute the sanctuary of strength,
and shall take away the daily, and they
shall place the abomination that makes
desolate."
So Martin in this system they will
replace the redemptive plan with
something
else. They will make it desolate. Now
here is a picture of what happened in
that court when you came into the court
with your sacrificial lamb. You placed
your hand upon it and you confessed your
sins and he took your place.
right now. Whether you believe that the
daily that is taken away is Rome that is
taken away or whether you believe that
it's a taking away of the
atonement really they are so
interconnected that it's hard to
separate them. It's because Rome took
away the atonement. Yes. And now when
you take away the atonement you are
taking away the role of the Messiah
which means you are making the
desolate because if Christ is no longer
in it, it's desolate. What? So either it
gets its fullness from Christ.
Verse 11 says, "And from the time that
the daily because sacrifice is added
there, shall be taken away and the
abomination that makes desolate shall be
set up there shall be
a,290 days." Now, we're not going to go
into this prophecy, but it's related to
the
1,260 days, just lengthened by 30 days
or 30 years because the decree that the
bishop should have this power went out
30 years before it went into effect, but
it still falls into the 2,300. Correct.
So, it has to do with the rise of the
papal system which would bring about
this desolation.
So just as the temple was desolate, so
Rome will be desolate. Yes. Fallen fall.
Could it be that Protestants will become
desolate as well if they align with it?
Yes. Because that's why God says come
out.
Jeremiah 12:10. This is now just this is
the prophet that is speaking before the
destruction. It's happening in his time.
Yeah. Many pastors have destroyed my
vineyards. They have trotten my portion
underfoot. They've made my pleasant
portion a desolate
waste. They had removed the doctrine of
salvation and replaced it with a
doctrine of works. Yes. Bottom line,
another system that is associated with
the period of papal rule will do exactly
the
same just under another pretext. Yeah.
Okay. Let's continue our story.
Then Jeremiah continues and he says they
have made it desolate.
Who? The Jews. The Jews themselves. They
made it desolate. How did they make it
desolate? By
removing the typology of a Messiah that
would die in their place and replacing
it with a system of works. Works. They
did the
ritual instead of going to who what the
ritual was for. Yes. and being desolate,
it mourneth unto me. He was a weeping
prophet. The whole land is made
desolate. If you remove the Messiah out
of your religion, then the whole land is
desolate if they swallow it because no
man layeth it to heart. Martin, if the
plan of salvation is not the key to the
block,
you've lost the plot, right? the
desolate worth nothing. That's why
Jesus when he was there and they
rejected him, he said, "Behold, your
house is left unto you desolate." And
verily I say unto you, you shall not see
me until the time come when you shall
say, blessed is he that comes in the
name of the Lord. That's the second
coming. Yeah. Yeah. So, Martin, there's
no nonsense about a sec a third temple
that will be built. Even if it is, it's
got nothing to do with this because that
desolation is until the second coming.
Correct? So we read in the signs of the
times that the sin of the Jews was very
great. But those in our day who have
before them the history of Christ upon
the earth and his rejection by the Jews
sin is far greater degree.
So they sin in a far greater
degree. They have the testimony of the
followers of Jesus through the period of
nearly
2,000 years. What time period is she
speaking about? 2,000 years after
Christ. Okay. There must be more or less
now, right? Must be.
They have far greater light than had the
Jews. All other errors are trifling
compared with the sin of rejecting
Christ. To turn from him is to reject
infinite truth, love, and righteousness,
and to close the door of the heart to
all heavenly
illumination, and to welcome darkness
and despair to accept him is light,
peace, and joy. The issue hasn't
changed. No. No. It's been the same
issue from Cain. It's still right
through till today. When you don't go
Christ's way, it's desolation for you.
It's desolation. It's the way of Cain or
the way of
Abel. So now when I read in Revelation
3:18 and uh I'm reading here a letter
that applies directly to God's remnant
church in the last days. Those that keep
the commandments and hold to the
testimony or supposed to do
that. Why should they be counseledled to
buy gold tried in the fire? In other
words, a character that is Christlike
that is molded in the fire of affliction
that you may be rich and white
raignment. The righteousness of Christ
is what it is about. That thou mayest be
clothed and not have your own filthy
rags on. And that the shame of your
nakedness, your sinful nature does not
appear. And anoint your eyes with eyesol
that thou may see. Is it possible that
even the elect can be
deceived? And you can think that a
system that puts the name of Jesus in
its mouth but denies him and calls
everything that pertains to him an
anathema. That that is problematic. For
sure. Well, unfortunately a lot will
still be blind.
So the door of the heart must be open to
the Holy Spirit for this is the
sanctifier and the truth is the medium.
There must be an acceptance of the truth
as it is in Jesus. That's the core of
the
matter. This is the only genuine
sanctification. The word of truth. Oh
read the prayer of Christ for unity.
Keep through thine own name those whom
thou hast given me that they may be one
as we are. Martin, there's so much
division in the world in the church.
Yes, in the church. The prayer of Christ
is not only for those who are now his
disciples, but for all those who shall
believe on Christ through the words of
his disciples, even to the end of the
world. Jesus was just about to yield up
his life to bring life and immortality
to light. Christ amidst his sufferings
and being daily rejected of men, looks
down the lines
2,000 years. It's not
2,500. It's not 1,800
to his church, which would be existence
in the last days before the clothes of
earth's history. Martin, I'm just
throwing that in there to show where we
are in the stream of time. Well, I don't
know. I've seen three witnesses now in
the with three citations here. Roman,
isn't it 2,50 years maybe or 2,90 years
or who knows? 4,000 years. It's an
inclusive amount.
All right. What's it all about? Bottom
line is righteousness by faith. That's
it. In verity. Yeah.
So, the third angel's message. Several
have written to me inquiring if the
message of justification by faith is the
third angel's message.
which says do not accept the mark of the
beast. That's it. And I have answered it
is the third angel's message in verity
and completeness.
Keeping the Sabbath they say is works
but you're resting. But you're resting.
So how do you work and rest at the same
time? I don't know.
That's the dichotomy that Satan is
promoting. Whereas on the Sunday
according to the catechism of the Roman
Catholic Church, you have to do a
sacrifice. Oh, that sounds like works.
Which is the mass.
Now I thought the sacrifice had already
been made. Yeah. One. So now you're
working towards another
sacrifice. Uh by one sacrifice you have
been made perfect. In other words,
justified.
So what are all these other sacrifices
about? Isn't that what the Jews did?
Yeah. Didn't they get involved in
sacrifice after sacrifice and the
sacrifice became the work and not the
essence of the sacrifice which was
Christ?
Isn't it exactly the same as the Jews
did just in another form? Yeah.
Okay. So in other words, Jesus is the
only hope of the soul by faith which is
an anathema by the way according to
them. Every soul may say what the
psalmist, whom have I in heaven but
thee? And there's none upon the earth
that I desire besides thee. The moment
the sinner lays hold of Christ by faith,
his sins are no longer upon him. Christ
stands in the sinner's place and
declares, "I have borne his guilt. I
have been punished for his
transgression. I have taken his sins and
put my righteousness upon him.
Martin, does it say there I have to go
to a earthly priest? I have to confess
my sins to him and he gives me
absolution and Christ has to abide by my
decision as a priest and either to
pardon or not to pardon. But you still
have to pay the price for your sin.
Therefore, you will go to purgatory and
burn it off. And the only one who can
give you uh release from that purgatory
is the pope who will apply the merit of
Mary or one of the saints or maybe even
Jesus to you so that you can get time
off in heaven. Does it say that? No, not
at all. It also does not say that Christ
says I will help him to become
righteous. What
Protestant can sign a document where the
pope becomes primate as long as the
doctrine of purgatory persists? This
impossible. It's impossible, right? But
they do.
So if you accept the primacy of the
papacy while the doctrine of purgatory
exists and Pope Francis gives you time
off in purgatory for following his
tweets.
Can you sit in that council? There's no
way.
Something's wrong here in the world,
isn't it? But that righteousness is not
never yours. No, it's always Christ's
righteousness. In Christ, the sinner
stands guiltless before the law. But how
vain is the hope of entering heaven if
we have no present faith in Christ. No
delight in spiritual things, no joy in
anticipating the joys of heaven. The
child of God finds his comfort and peace
in Christ. He delights to dwell upon the
holiness of his future immortal home.
And not on a golden age down here,
Martin. Nope. Sorry.
of dominance and power that will be
temporal prosperity and sudden
destruction. So the Lord commands, "Be
ye holy, for I am holy." The Christian's
constant endeavor should be to come into
perfect confformity to the life of
Christ. We must look away from the
darkness and face the light. Do not by
your attitude of unbelief charge God
with partiality or
unfaithfulness. Your doubts cast
reflection upon the verity of his
promises. This is what we must do. When
in living faith you come to Jesus and
become doers of the word. You will taste
and see that the Lord is good. You will
say by his stripes we are healed. This
is true religion. Yeah. Do we hear it?
No. No. We see Ashvenge their crosses
and we see this that and the other and
dominionism and power and all of this
nonsense and we will control the world.
Didn't the Jews say that? Yeah. Didn't
they want to chase the Romans out and
become the rulers of the world? That's
it. That's the way they wanted Christ to
be king. That's what they were. In
actual fact, they still they're still
waiting for the same Messiah to come and
do that. So if you have this religion,
you will think of Jesus, you will talk
of Jesus as the one who is willing and
able to save to the uttermost. This is
it. He who believes in Jesus Christ as
your savior, he perfect obedience is set
to your account. His obedience, not
mine. This is the bottom line. You are
pardoned as you look to Jesus as your
substitute and charity. The promise is
if we confess our sins, he's faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness. Not
this pomp and ceremony and nonsense and
rituals and fasts and and fishburgers
and you name it. None of that is going
to count as one
iota. None of it. It sounds like when
Simon Magus wanted to buy the Holy
Spirit. You can't do it. You can't do
it.
So, let's just read the highlighted
portions of this. Christ came to our
world to reshape the deformed character
of man, not to build a grand
empire. It was a very crooked character
that he came to reform.
I must admit that that is what he did.
I've I've got bad news for you. You have
a very deformed character that needs to
be reformed. I know that. And I'm glad
that I don't have to try and do it. Yes.
That he has done. He reforms it. Your
wife reminds you of it. Yeah.
Then the rich promise is that we shall
be partakers of the divine nature. Why
this means everything to us to be a
partaker of the divine nature Martin?
It's by beholding that we become
changed. Not by rituals, not by
pilgrimages, not by numerous pairs
prayers and
chastisements, nor by fish burgers. No.
And I'm not knocking a fish burger. If
you like it, go and eat it. I have no
problem with that. But if it becomes a
necessity because you have to perform a
certain thing to be declared righteous,
then you're wasting your time. It's the
same with the spiritual formation type
of things. It's no wonder if you're
going to sit and you repeat something to
try and get closer to God or imagine
things. This is the same. It's all doing
things to try and appease him. Exactly.
So he's
Ba. He's not Christ then. So no wonder
Titus says in
3:5, "Not by works of righteousness
which we have done, but according to his
mercy he saved us by the washing of
regeneration and renewing of the Holy
Ghost." Martin, this is again an
anathema. Yeah.
or Ephesians, that in the ages to come
he might show the exceeding riches of
his grace in his kindness towards us
through Christ Jesus. For by grace you
are saved through faith and that not of
yourselves. It is a gift of God. I
cannot attain it through my works.
But I can show that I have attained it
by good works. It flows out because
faith without works is dead. People
don't understand that. No, it's a
consequence, not a means. It's just
turning the the cart backwards. The
problem comes in with self because as
soon as you do it the other way around,
you
become holy.
Martin, your wife probably reminds you
numerous times that you're not yet holy.
You're still on a road struggling along.
If the church could see you now,
yeah. Yeah.
Not of works, lest any man should boast.
For we are his workmanship, created in
Christ Jesus unto good works, which God
has before ordained that we should walk
in them. Will there be good works? It
will flow out. Of course, but not yours.
No, you have nothing to boast. It is him
working in you the works of
righteousness. So, there are diverging
paths of truth and error.
Satan's angels are wise to do evil, and
they will create that which some claim
to be advanced light and will proclaim
it as new and
wonderful. Yet, while in some respects
the message may be truth, it will be
mingled with human inventions and will
teach for doctrines the commandments of
men. So, if you accept traditions rather
than scripture, that's a mingling,
right? And it can there will be some
light in it, but there's poison in there
as well. If there was ever a time when
we should watch and pray in real
earnest, it is now. Many apparently good
things will need to be carefully
considered. The whole world at the
moment is clapping. Yeah.
Because many apparently good things are
happening which need to be carefully
considered. Where's it
going? With much prayer for they are
species devices of the enemy to lead
souls in a path which lies so close to
the path of truth that it will be
scarcely distinguishable from it. Is it
possible? This is what we are up against
right now. Right now. But the eye of
faith may discern that it is diverging.
It's taking you in another direction.
Though almost imperceptibly from the
right path. At first it may be thought
positively right, but after a while it
is seen to be widely divergent from the
way which leads to holiness in heaven.
My brethren, I warn you to make a
straight path for your feet, lest the
lame be turned out of the way. Martin,
this is what's happening in the world.
So that means you must be able to read
the writing on the wall. You must be
able to read it because otherwise you
are walking the wrong path. Correct.
Heresies now presented as Bible
doctrine. Mhm. We see hundreds of them.
Hundreds of them. The time has come when
we cannot depend upon the doctrine which
comes to our ears unless we see that it
harmonizes with the word of God. There
are dangerous heresies that will be
presented as Bible doctrines and we are
to become acquainted with the Bible so
that we may know how to meet them. The
faith of every individual will be tested
and everyone will pass through a trial
of close criticism. M we are in that
time. So we need to be sober like Peter
says vigilant because our adversary the
devil is a roaring lion walking about
seeking whom we may devour. If we do not
understand how the socalled beautiful
things that are happening are diverging
from the path of
salvation. Then we likewise will be
blaspheming the
sanctuary. the
tabernacle. So it is a gradual stealing
upon us this crisis. The sun shines in
the heavens passing over its usual
round. Men are still eating and
drinking, jostling one against another.
The highest excitement prevails. Yet
probation's hour is fast closing and the
door of mercy might be shut very soon.
Martin, would you agree with that? I
agree.
So, let's get a little bit
serious. Revelation 18 says, "And after
these things, I saw another angel come
down from heaven, having great power,
and the earth was lightened with his
glory. And he cried mightily with a
strong voice, saying, Babylon the great
is fallen.
She has become the habitation of devils
and the hold of every foul spirit and a
cage of every unclean and hateful bird.
So there's a false Holy Spirit. Yeah.
Devils are in
there. And if that is the case, is Jesus
in there then? No, not at all. So have
they become desolate? Yes.
Can the churches become desolate?
Definitely. Be For sure. I mean, this
unclean, hateful bird is part of the
churches and it's a false spirit. Yeah.
If the spirit says to you, you do not
have to keep the law. And Jesus says, if
you love me, you will keep the
commandments, then the two are
obviously, you know, in juxiposition to
each other. The one is from the devil
and the other one not. It's hateation of
devils. And if justification is now by
grace alone and not by faith alone and
it is in the works of Christ and not in
the atoning blood of Christ, then what
doctrine is that? Is that a doctrine
from the Holy Spirit or is a doctrine of
the devil?
Devil, huh? Yeah. Doctrine of the devil.
Okay. It's opposite Christ. And so when
the Bible says that they drunk have
drunken of the wine of the wroth of her
fornication and that the kings of the
earth that's plural
have committed fornication with her and
the merchants of the earth are waxed
rich through the abundance of her
delicacies because it's all controlled
by the knights of Malta and the Jesuits.
And I had another voice from saying the
only solution now is to come out of her
my people. That voice is God's voice.
That's God's voice. But it has to get to
the people through the voice of
humanity.
Yes. That you be not partakers of her
sins, her transgression of the law, and
you receive not of her plagues.
Martin, the churches are desolate.
They've become Babylon. Yeah. And if
there are any of these Babylonian
components in our church, thoughts, yes,
and ways, music, all of this, that'll
make us desolate. Get get rid of it.
Come out of it. Yes. Absolutely.
So when the work of investigation shall
be
ended, when the cases of those who in
all ages have professed to be followers
of Christ have been examined and
decided, then and not till then
probation will close and the door of
mercy will be shut. Thus, in one short
sentence, they that were ready went in
with him to the marriage, and the door
was shut. We are carried down through
the Savior's final ministration to the
time when the great work for man's
salvation shall be completed. And
Martin, when Christ came the first time,
he worked in the outer court, right?
Yeah. Because he was not a Levite. He
was from the tribe of
Judah. And from there he became the
priest of the order of
Mechisedc. And he went and ministered in
the holy place in the heavenly sanctuary
which Paul says not made by human hands.
But the earthly sanctuary under the Jews
carried on sacrificing. They didn't
realize that the house was desolate. So
they had their ritual and their system
and their pump and their glamour and it
was totally useless
because
your
ministration and your religion should be
heavenly focused to an advocate who up
there was going to take care of your
events. Right? Yeah.
So when he moved into the holy place and
the Jews rejected that move and carried
on in their earthly sanctuary,
their house was desolate. Yeah. So now
at the end of the
2,300 day prophecy which ended in
1844 when the emphasis was placed on
Christ's ministration shifting to the
most holy place. Yes. Where the law was.
Yes.
Then the law was made prominent and the
Sabbath was made pro prominent and
justification by faith was again made
prominent.
The church has rejected it. Yes. They
stayed in the in the holy. Then doesn't
the house become desolate? Exactly the
same. Desolate. Who fills the lack? Who
fills the emptiness? Satan. Satan with
his demons and a false holy spirit.
That's what we've just read. So the one
message is come back into harmony with
the law, those that keep the
commandments of God and hold to the
testimony. And the other message is no,
you don't have to because the law has
been done away with. And if the law has
not been done away with, we'll keep the
paper law and not the one. So we'll
change one seal for another seal. We
cannot be sealed with the seal of God,
but we receive the mark of the beast.
So the danger of what I was mentioning
earlier as well is you can be sitting in
the correct church. Yes. But you can
have that Babylonian mindset of music
and all this in your house, your
spiritual temple. There's this one gets
temporary. So when I say get out of it,
I don't mean leave that church. Get out
of that mindset. Come out of that
Babylonian mindset. But if your church
refuses to keep the commandments of God
and
negates the justification principle and
accepts a papal form of it, then you've
become part of Babylon and you have to
come out of that system including that
church that belongs to that system.
Desolation is destruction and that is
what is going to happen to that system.
So that is why the third angel in
revelation 14 says with a very loud
voice if any man worship the
beast and it's very simple those that
you have chosen to obey is the one that
you are
worshiping or his
image that is the same principle coming
to the four in Protestant the United
States of America and receive his mark
in the forehead or in his hand the same
shall drink of the wroth of God
because they're desolate, Martin,
they've become a house of
demons. And I heard another out of the
altar say, "Even so, Lord God Almighty,
true and righteous are your judgments."
That's Revelation 16:7.
So when they receive the plagues and the
judgments fall upon them, they all
complain and try to get rid of those
that keep the commandments. Yeah. Right.
We spoke about that last time. But the
Bible declares that the judgments are
righteous. Was Jerusalem destroyed? Yes.
They rejected Christ. Yep.
Will Babylon be destroyed? Will the
world be destroyed? Because they have
rejected him again and accepted
falsehoods in the place thereof and
compromises which negate him. like the
Abrahamic accord who's totally
Christless who's left behind there I
mean you can have citation ecumenical
councils Jesus is put on the same level
as Buddha and all of this exactly
he's as soon as you get rid of Jesus
your house is going to be left desolate
that's the whole point of this
discussion if we do not center upon
Christ we're desolate we have lost the
plot So Martin, that's the bottom line.
Yeah. He
blasphemed those that are in heaven. He
blasphemes the
tabernacle. Martin, we've seen it over
and over again. And so we move from the
Jews where the house became desolate
because they rejected him
to Catholicism which became desolate
because they rejected him. to
Protestantism that has compromised with
a desolate system and a desolate the
theology and have become desolate. Yeah.
I don't want to be desolate. No. Because
if I don't have him, I don't have
salvation. I prefer to be in anathema
and cling to him. Yes. Rather than cling
to a system which cannot save. Amen.
Let's pray.
Heavenly
Father, it is all about Jesus Christ. We
spoke in a previous one, Lord, about the
the
centrality of
Christ. But we need to understand how
people can appear to embrace you while
rejecting your plan of
salvation. The one is as bad as the
other. help us to have eyes of that we
may see is my prayer in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.
[Music]